were you excited to see tonight I have  to imagine you know a little bit and  studying Nashville as much as you had  you know some of these performers are  Nick Jonas is gonna be here he's really  talented Nick Jonas fan Tom Hiddleston  hit up the ACM Awards on Sunday looking  dapper and addressing rumors he'll be  done playing Loki after thor ragnarok  you recently said that thor 3 is going  to be your last outing know that I did  say that I read it maybe you were miss  opponent don't believe everything you  read oh ok so you're not done with Loki  well it is the thing I love movies  myself and I love going to see stuff and  I like to be surprised so I'm actually  not going to tell you not because so I  think it's better I just prefer for the  audience to have to be surprised you  have to wait see